tell me if this voice sounds familiar
sweet lion of Zion
what about this one in brightest day in
blackest night okay you definitely know
this one fifty years have passed we
could easily keep going through his 300
other characters but let's just cut to
the chase and meet the man behind the
voice this is Phil Lamarr and he's a
voice actor I'd say the ones that I'm
probably best known for hoodies Code Red
certified bureaucrat from the show
Futurama
[Music]
Berta Virgil Hawkins aka static shock
from the steady shot drawn Steve
remindin from justice named Williams the
weatherman from Family Guy Holly
Williams has the story Holly I'm at the
wrong Airport oops well thanks Ali
will't impulses home for imaginary
friends one of my favorites is Dracula
from the grim adventures of Billy and
Mandy and of course the summit I know me
as Jack from the cities of the same name
he who wears a mask cannot see what lies
within himself when I was working on
pulp fiction wait you were in pulp
fiction of course yeah here let me jog
your memory
Marvin Marvin
I've knocked it [ __ ] off oh you're
Marvin and I was one of the original
cast members on Fox's MADtv no way I
love MADtv and you must have been a
fourteen-year-old boy in the 90s
very funny Phil anyway you were saying
what's my jack I felt there should be
Sonny tie to his roots so it was a very
light Japanese accent on English Queen
again to be referred to as a young Asian
Clint Eastwood voice and Hermes from
Futurama where did that voice come from
when I first started out doing did you
make an accent for Hermes he was pretty
much in a heavy pot well and it it
muddied up the comedy so eventually your
Hermes exit got pulled back which is a
lot easier to understand what about Jon
Stewart from Justice League to me if
you've got a chest this big you gotta
have a deep voice my name is Jon Stewart
green lands in a sector to eight one
four and how about static shock that
voice was basically just myself at 14 it
was just that idea of you know a young
kid you know who's a responsible guy but
you know he just happens to have
electrical powers and to me that is the
character I relate to the most
you know static is just you know me the
difference is between stage film voice
acting a really technical that plane
leaves are no not on it you're gonna
regret it
one of the benefits we have in animation
is I can play this guy and I can also
play this guy you'll see what I'm
talking about just right there in the
same day same room same microphone you
know cuz that's why we got into these
play characters you will bow before the
column
[Music]